at the end of the day everything comes
down to our ability
to get people what they want when they
want it
and that is such it's such a strong
capability
and there's so many things to build
around that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
this is one of those episodes where in
10 years i'll look back and say wow
this is maybe where it all began we're
going to talk about retail
and deliveries and micro mobility and
all of that together and how that's
going to change the way
we as traditional consumers in our life
consume the things we need whether it's
food electronics
groceries and anything in between meet
omelette the director of retail sales
and growth at walt
omer's director of resell retail sales
at walt leading walt's global efforts
regards to its expansion from restaurant
delivery to new verticals like grocery
florists electronics and more
before joining walt he served as a
commander in a technology unit in the
israel army
practiced law as a high-tech lawyer and
one of the leading law firms in israel
and spent five years in hp indigo as
head of business operations in indigo's
growth team
omeglev welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you today
i'm i'm good how are you i've been
waiting so long for this episode
director of retail sales and growth at
walt you're
literally working on the thing that i've
been thinking about every day
as i see thousands of blue
scooters riding around tel aviv and i
just think when is going to be the day
that i can order
anything i want and get it delivered
within 30 minutes
without me having to leave the house and
so i'm
excited to pick your brain yeah yeah so
actually
that's the vision right exactly that so
so hopefully soon
but but let's talk about it all right so
you know we'll get to this to this grand
vision
uh we're not there yet right now i'm
ordering about three times a day food
and and the you know the regular things
for the house but
share with me a little bit about what
you know your entrance to walt
and a little bit about your perspective
on what's happening here with this
consumer behavior that has obviously
already been transformed both due to
covet
but also due to walt's entrance into the
israeli market
yeah so funny story i mean i
i worked for hp indigo uh as a growth
team leader
uh for for five years and i decided it
was time to
to leave and i heard in riga who was um
he was the gm of israel at the time he's
now uh in a more senior role
i heard him in the podcast tell about
walt and i was like wow
this sounds really cool i i want to be a
part of it it was thursday night
i went to my wife she wasn't my wife and
i said
uh i really want to work there um
she said yeah go for it so i looked at
the website it was
there was nothing relevant uh i said
okay i'll wait and the following morning
like literally the following morning i
got a
linkedin approach from finland uh
asking if i'll be interested to uh uh
interview for
like uh no way of business development
yeah yeah way uh so that was really
a a match made in heaven and the process
was kind of
uh amazing and i i started as
a head of global business development so
even though it was based in israel i was
supposed to kind of
globally look at opportunities that we
had on that front
um but then coveted
and i was just a month in the company
like i didn't have what to do yet
uh so he came to me he said look there's
this covet thing
we don't know what's going to happen
exactly but we know that
whatever happens supermarkets are going
to stay open
and pharmacies are going to stay open so
can you take a look
at working with pharmacies and and
supermarkets
um and and walt's brand was
this is so strong here in israel it was
so good that i was fortunate
to to kind of close two deals with
public companies
in like three weeks so so the first
three weeks
yeah so it was like with paz uh for
yellow for like their convenience
uh store chains and then like three
times a week for me
yeah and then like the ten days after it
was with chufa sal for bee farm which is
kind of fast
um so those were the two first
retail uh we say retail we say like
everything beyond restaurants
um right that was the first two kind of
big wall
signings across the world for retail and
by doing those
we just learned so much about
consumer preferences about partner
preferences about
how many gaps do we have in in the app
and in the operations and in everything
we have
that don't fit kind of retail
um okay way too many questions i have uh
popping in right now yeah
the first one is why is it that when i
look out my window on disingolf i see
five walt scooters at any given moment
how do you explain that is this
happening all around the world
is israel some you know case study that
is different perhaps
so uh i would say it's everywhere around
the world there are definitely more
countries
with this phenomenon um i think
in that podcast that i heard a year and
almost a half ago when he we
interviewed we were smaller but still
really big and he was asked the same
question
so if you said five maybe i don't know
they said two
or three but but his answer was
we didn't do anything new
we just did everything really really
well so
yes like customer experience is good
service is good the delivery is on time
that everything around the customer
experience is just so smooth and so
easy um so i think that's the reason
and and to be fair i have nothing to do
with that like
like everything happened before before
me but but
going back to to retail so what was very
interesting for us is that
in our vision we said we want to go
into like more than restaurants but it's
going to take time and we want to be
ready for it like we want to change the
product we want to change everything
not in 2020 we will see but
kovi just made us do it and
and we were like i don't know i mean
this doesn't fit
like like uh retail it just
it should be completely different but we
were shocked
by how successful it was
and how much did people uh react to it
and just started ordering so so we had
like
so many people ordering i mean it was
funny like
at the time people were stocking up
everything and there were no eggs
i don't know if you remember like april
2020 there was no eggs
like the best place to get eggs was in
tel aviv at least because we were in tel
aviv at that time
was through yellow uh on wall so so they
just stopped
every day with more eggs than they ever
had and people would go on
and and do that and we ran
surveys to see how satisfied customers
were and we were like
this isn't good enough this should be
better like we should have a better
retail experience for for customers it's
just like an mvp that we released
but people were happy like yeah it's
great i enjoy
ordering i enjoy the experience
everything is good
um yes so we were surprised i mean we
we have so we started again here in
israel and then it grew and grew and
became from this kind of small anecdote
to something that we're going to invest
in heavily in the future
um amazing and it started in israel but
now it's in all 23 markets we have
over 2500 retail partners from
everything from
grocery to florets to bakeries to
alcohol stores butcher shops
um and we just launched like in israel
like a gift shop
um like a few gift chops and
going back to what you said in the
beginning when you were thinking how can
i get everything in 30 minutes
um that's what we that's where we want
to go uh
and we want to help stores
um of any kind kind of be available
and get access to a lot of customers and
also allow customers
to get whatever they want uh in in a
click of a button
if i think you know the consumer
behavior here is
you know for me i can feel how it's
going to change my perspective
on the shopping experience you know one
of the things that i hate
most or you know i i get nauseous when i
enter a clothing store i don't know what
it is it runs in my family and
you know especially the men but i'm
thinking to myself you know if i could
order this one pair of jeans and have it
delivered to me
and i don't have to commit to this whole
buying experience of going
in trying out this expectation of making
it you know this big event
then i'm a whole new type of customer
that's getting introduced not to just
walt but to the whole world and it just
makes perfect sense to me you know
economics wise you know the supply and
demand
why every single small business or big
business would want to buy into this
yeah yeah so what you're saying makes
total sense but then
it also tells the story of how big
retail is and how complex it is
i mean take logos right like we will get
close like we will be there at some
point in time we don't know when
but everything around the return process
everything around that
is is such a big thing it's such a big
topic right right and it changes
everything it changes how we do
operations it changes the business model
it changes the whole
story like if you partner with a
restaurant
and and and you know you build a
business model based on kind of
the partner here there's like okay
what's the return
ratio like what percent of customers
returns how do they do it how
like there's so many things to consider
here and by the way that's what i
love about my job is that it's not
actually
one business that we're expanding into
it's
talking about like customer behavior so
two things that i have in mind and that
we had is a vision so we said we want to
get like butcher shops and fish shops
uh on board and the plan was if you want
to cook something
or if you have a barbecue with friends
then
usually you need to prepare in advance
you need to go to look at your shop
think about it whatever like every time
me and my friends you want to do a
barbecue and like okay who's going to go
to jaffa and buy
and i'm thinking no you just you do this
and in 20 minutes
you get whatever you want and and i i if
you're talking about changing consumer
behavior
then i want that mindset to to
to be for everyone so you don't need to
plan
almost anything that's like where we
want to go and another example on that
and
is the supermarkets so instead of doing
like
one big purchase okay you buy what you
need
when you need it like this right if it's
cheap enough
then why the hell not uh so that's kind
of the
consumer behavior that that that we want
to generate and
we're starting to see which is so
fascinating
and fun what i think is most exciting
for me you know in our discussion is
that you know
up until now i almost feel like you know
we've talked and talked about you know
almost the obvious layers that anybody
who would think concretely enough or
would take
you know the basic you know macro micro
economics what it would get to but
you know they're so their butterfly
effect of this is so
great the way people the relationships
with
with small businesses this idea of
warehouses within
dense cities you know the transition
from small businesses to you know
all of that you know we're not even
talking about those side effects and i
think you know obviously time will tell
what happens but i think it
it's a it's such an interesting you know
position to be in where you're
at where you get to even hypothesize how
your product is going to completely
change
the way every player in the market is
going to operate it's pretty incredible
it is and again you're you're on par i
mean you talked about warehouses
we already have three four retail
businesses
that are warehouses that were open just
for us
uh 20 meter 20 square meter warehouses
that are incredible businesses like
incredible
uh really really good uh and not just
like in many many markets
uh and we're seeing more and more of
this and and again in a way it's
it's like the merchants and the partners
they're more advanced than we are like
they do it
like we didn't before we thought about
it they would go and do it they would
say
guys you don't understand what you have
here like you can change
like the way people do business you
could change like the way
people live their lives and it's it's a
very uh
it's like a big vision right but it's
possible i mean at the end of the day
everything comes
down to our ability to get people what
they want
when they want it and that is such it's
such a strong capability
and there's so many things to build
around that
uh and you mentioned that there but
there's so many players on top like
brands you know companies that want to
do d2c uh
come like companies like unity for like
coca-cola like like
that's right you know these companies
they want to be a lot closer to the
consumer and they can use a platform
like that for so many things
um right so really like and i'm
every day my head is exploding with with
new ideas and new opportunities and i
wish to work
you know more hours in the day to to to
get to them
no no completely you know i'll give one
last example personally and obviously
you can tell
how excited i'm about about everything
that i'm observing here i remember the
first time that i ordered from a
restaurant i really enjoyed the meal and
only after i got the food i real my
friend told me
you know this is a really high-end
restaurant like this is like a crazy
expensive restaurant
i ordered like a 60 shekel appetizer
because i wanted that specific meal that
was my dinner
and i was like wow like i would never
have gone into this restaurant myself
because it would be too scary and too
intimidating to order
you know to commit to a full meal and
now i get to be
and they're you know they're able to
enjoy me as a consumer
consumer and i'm able to enjoy this
really specific meal that i just really
wanted
everything is being democratized and i
think it's awesome and what i really
want to also pick your brain about oh no
is you know this the onboarding you
mentioned that it took you know within a
span of three weeks
or ten days you got you know two huge
retailers in israel
how is the reception from retailers as
as you're coming to them are they
surprised are they immediately on board
what is sort of the experience you have
with them
it varies so much i mean restaurants
whether they did deliveries or not they
know the game
like like it's been around for so long
they understand the math they wouldn't
even know us
and i'm not just talking about israel
i'm talking globally but for retailers
like we've had discussions where they
didn't know us
which was a new thing for us like we're
like restaurants notes and we have to go
to the room and they're like oh
okay who are you what what are you doing
why
why is that important and then there's
so many ranges because a lot of players
already have their e-commerce solution
but for four days delivery or three days
delivery right
uh and it's just a completely different
thing it's a completely different cost
like everything is so different about
that so
there are cases where smaller merchants
are like
jumping on board because they see an
opportunity for them to to get on top of
this like wagon and to get
that them up democratization that you
mentioned where
they could be out there next to like the
super famous restaurant and maybe
somebody will be exposed and order
a flower that from floors that they
never heard of or stuff like that so
there's like this
super small merchants that are really
hungry uh
bigger ones it's it's a lot more
difficult it's a lot more challenging
and it requires a lot more
uh conviction again looking at those two
partners like paz
and and and b pharma their leaders
were so amazing and so receptive and so
kind of open to the idea and seeing hey
like they they understood like hey guys
there's kobe
like people are gonna need these things
now right so they were also really
really cool
but just to be fair like most of our
cooperations with these kind of
partners take many many months like to
to sign which is another capability that
we have to develop
as a company like moving from selling to
small businesses to starting to
like huge visits no i i completely agree
and i have to say that you know i feel
that i'm sort of like
already adopting this behavior what i
know what i'm noticing is that when i
know that i want something from a store
what i've ended up doing this past few
months both because of covet but
honestly because you know i think that
i'm representing the next generation of
consumers is
i call them up i make the order i pay
and then i order i get delivery
unfortunately it costs a little bit more
than than walt i guess would would take
for that delivery but
you know but but it already makes
perfect sense to me you know for these
25 shekels
why would i or you know five five six
dollars why would i make this hour long
trip to the store if i know exactly what
i want and i'm assuming that a lot of
times
we go to a store because we know what we
want so
i fully agree and and that's where we're
coming
you're not all the customers there's a
lot of customers that 25 circles but by
the way well delivery is a lot cheaper
uh like the base is 10 right in israel
and we have a really cheap delivery
policy
across markets but putting that aside
let's talk about the example you gave
25 seconds 20 for a lot of people that
that's not worth it but that's fine
but there is a growing layer of people
that that say hey i i would pay 20
to save an hour of my time without
thinking like it's not
it's not even a thought process like
friday morning
uh in friday or like saturday and other
markets you see customers
certain like that order from five
different places
right so that's how they do their
shopping like they get up in the morning
this is okay they got a bakery from here
like bread from the bakery
uh right meatloaf like that's what they
do and
it costs them i don't know 15
on on on delivery but they save three
hours and they're super happy
and we see more and more of these
customers then
um that's one thing and another thing is
discovery
so right i want to buy a gift right like
like somebody gave birth
somebody moved somebody has a birthday i
want to buy a gift okay
well gifts 30 options
three clicks and it's there right uh
so so that's another thing that we're
really working on and
starting to see more and more that's a
fantastic omer
thank you so much for your time 20
minutes is not nearly enough to cover
this
exactly that's how i feel every time are
you ready for three fun questions
yeah for sure let's do it all right
favorite subject in school k-12
so it's like bible uh
but wow the reason is like yeah yeah
but i had the best teacher ever i was i
was a bit of a
smart ass in school and i was i was
different
like i had good i had good grades like i
was a good student but i was a bit of a
smart ass and i
i thought i was smarter than everyone i
love it
was like she whipped me like i was
afraid of her
uh and for her lessons i was like quiet
and
and she taught me a lot as a person and
she taught bible and
and she made it interesting and fun uh
so
my favorite teacher is my favorite
subject i love it
one of your role models
i i guess that's the biggest cliche ever
um
by my dad uh hey and the reason is that
my dad had an incredible career like
amazing
uh he was like one of the the the chief
officers in a big bank in israel um
and he worked really really hard but he
also gave us
everything like like like i never felt
that he wasn't there
ever i thought he was there more than
than than he should have um
and that balance for me it's amazing
like like being able to
to work that hard and succeed that much
in your life but also
giving your family kind of the the
sentiment that
you're always there for them and
supporting them and i revealed my dad
so i love that okay and three words you
would use to describe yourself
i would say versatile
obsessive and
uh humorous so i
joke all the time
about everything anything i'm obsessive
i mean when i'm
when i'm thinking about something i i
i'm not gonna let go for for better or
worse
uh and i i tried to build my career in
this kind of versatile layer of being
like
a lawyer and having kind of technology
background and business
um so i guess
thank you very very much this was
wonderful
stay safe and stay healthy i can't wait
to continue following this amazing
journey
it's just incredible uh so thank you for
the inspiration
thank you for allowing me to get you
know food
groceries pharmacy and soon everything
else that i need
in a matter of minutes and stay safe and
stay healthy
yeah so the last one is not me but
but i'll think well on behalf and again
thank you it was it was great fun
uh so thank you thank you very much take
care bye
[Music]